il était pourtant supporter
la ceinture
je crains qu'on va fêter cette année
j'ai pris les organisateurs qui ont gelé
ces duels sont d'une caméra que les
idées d'un produit une doré qui
représente
l'accueil des populations comme du monde
c'est
sa couleur pâle en moi j'ai acheté je
vous ai déjà chômage doit rester aux
pays qui auront pour cadre et son pays
evariste en mars
quelle était la plus grande difficulté
pour toi ce soir sur le ring
l'a3 deuxième la troisième reprise
allait un peu pile dessus je me suis un
peu relâché parce que j'étais un petit
peu fatigué mais je recule d'assumer
quoi tu me motiver tout le public a
commencé
montée en puissance et la hd non
interdire interdire perdre ce soir j'ai
donné tout ce que j'avais j'ai pris
quelques coups mais bon je pense qu'elle
en a
plus que j'en aie aie
j'ai rencontré là c'est sûr et ce
n'était pas facile mais comme on dira
plus dur est là
et là qu'on a
victoire est la prochaine étape pour toi
me reposer c'est pas du tout qu'est ce
que je vais
l'année prochaine ou dans deux ans je
trouve à tenter un triplé jamais rien
pour le moment je savoure ma victoire
avec tous mes amis tous mes partenaires
tout ce qui monte
et après merci madame